welcome back to another episode of this
wonderful show that is called abba vs
preach where we uh play little games and
we talk a lot of [ __ ] boom
that's pretty much it we have uh we'll
see
in the back giving us the games one day
you'll see his face one day and we have
of course jp on the board thank you very
much for that let's go so what are we
playing today the game is family feud
and i will yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're to be a steve harvey
play the role you have too much beard to
be steve steve harvey yeah too much you
have too much beard to be sea barbie
and
not enough veneer like i feel like he is
just wham
yeah you ain't got the money
that's really what it comes down to that
nigga's rich that's
rich rich he got giraffe money we yeah
we could talk [ __ ] about steve harvey he
doesn't give a [ __ ] no
got that [ __ ] you money yeah yeah he's
got that family feud money yes you know
his family's feuding you see lori harvey
yeah she [ __ ] everybody yeah
she's out there in this cheats good for
her
how would you feel if all your daughters
out there [ __ ] every top named rapper
um
i don't know why i don't know i i i'm
like daughter go live your life but
there's something about it to me that's
us all right um yes because that
[ __ ] is dysfunctional
yes so it's like
you know if you already got a shady pass
and [ __ ] with the wrong dudes i'm
already looking at you funny
but if you're doing it with famous
people you announcing to everybody that
you love dysfunctional you know what i
mean yeah it's something weird about
that yeah i'm just gonna i would feel
like i [ __ ] up and it ain't got
nothing nothing to do with the sexual
liberation or whatever what not you can
do whatever you want to do it's the
process of how you do it you know you
have to be with us
so i would just feel like i failed yeah
something like that
if my daughter was just [ __ ] a bunch
of famous youtubers i'd be like i failed
yes yeah yeah it ain't got nothing to do
with like i rather you
[ __ ]
if you [ __ ] i know she's [ __ ] a whole
bunch of [ __ ] but a whole bunch
of randoms i wouldn't care if you
specifically go for famous [ __ ]
all the time i'd be like
that's weird me and me being famous and
now your name ends up in some diss
tracks
priest got a daughter i banged that
you know what i mean
i don't want like my name coming up here
if i come up in the youtube roast let me
imagine fresh and fit find out my
daughter out here getting ran through by
youtubers yeah and fresh feel like yo
amber
i'm like damn these [ __ ] got me
if if your daughter becomes a verb
you got britney renard goddamn i failed
i [ __ ] failed
oh yeah you laurie arvian [ __ ]
i failed there's some [ __ ] if you become
a verb it's just one dude okay it's just
youtube just
youtubers sucks that's us that's super
success
yeah i feel like i would yeah
i would know a name of a woman who
[ __ ] bill bird dave chappelle
richard pryor you [ __ ] all them guys
across different generations like i'mma
look at you funny you know what i'm
saying
like how you hop in all this top
community
[Music]
i don't know but i digress you're a
top-tier community dick that's right all
this is something [ __ ] all they say
will seem if you have a daughter just be
careful
i don't i don't have those veneers so i
don't know
it's like kim kardashian you don't think
her dad was just like ah this [ __ ] he
killed himself did he didn't even kill
himself damn i appreciate cancer right
yeah cancer okay maybe he's the one who
got oj maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe all
that deception gave him cancer yeah
that's how that's how that family got
rich yeah
dude's just a really good lawyer
yeah yeah
is it him that said persuades right if
the gloof
was that alan dershowitz is that his
name
no no no that's um another one of oj's
lawyers okay yeah because they were team
that was a team was it was it a black
guy in the the armenian dude it was a
team it was a whole team that was
dershowitz it was some it was the black
dude i forgot his name the black dude
said if if the glove don't fit you must
have quit that was the black the black
one because
lyrics like that you know it was
it was you know it was not the armenian
dude it was a black dude because yeah
yeah yeah you know what they're doing
talking [ __ ] i'd be like your
client's probably still guilty but bars
yeah
if i'm on the jury
armenian dude would have wouldn't spit
that that thing you would have sang it i
don't think you trust in the judicial
system or some [ __ ] like that you know
like armenian people would do no army
people like guys guys
guys guys
oj didn't do this
but my people suffered a channel
i would like the judge to acknowledge
that before
who was it that does that to the the
armenians the turks the church
the turks yeah
so what we got what we started with
uh so the game of family food very
briefly 100 people are polled in theory
and the the top answers they give in a
particular category are ranked by how
many people gave that particular answer
all right
so the way they'll do this is i'll give
you a topic
and the first person to answer
um
you get to go and guess again if you get
it wrong it's going to go to the bone
player all right well you can't just
spend like 30 seconds after your first
guess yeah yeah i'm going to give you
i'm going to give you in my head about a
a seven second timer okay i'll go
all right cool lori what was it lori
harvey there you go lori harvey
and then you change persons
that's a great concept on to the
that's just next man anyways
so we're dealing with numbers here so
i'm gonna be writing those i'm gonna be
writing those and then we'll figure that
out okay first category family feud
round number one
name something that might wake you up in
the middle of the night
just go ahead
nightmares
number two answer
kids
these are going to be frustrating
uh
an intruder
that is not on the board
your partner
not on the board
sexy time
no sexy time you know the poke in the
butt cheek
you don't you don't get a little a
little
okay all right um no it's my turn [ __ ]
it up yeah go for it all right you said
an intruder yeah i said an intruder
see sometimes there's leeway
so what happened there is a loud noise
is the number one answer that's no
loud noises
[Music]
all right we're taking that away so
there's there's we've said you said
nightmare that's 24 points we got three
more we've got the number three through
five answers all right um
lori harvey
that is on the board
lori army oh i make enough money for
lori army to wake me up at night god
damn all right i made it laurie imagine
that's how you know you made it [ __ ]
guess what [ __ ] lori rv just dropping
my dms who
need to pee i need to be having to use
the bathroom that's 17 points right
yes
um how about throw hell mary
i don't even think this is real
pets pets
on the board i don't think so the kids
are not on the boy
i'm like white people wake up
literally they would
being thirsty
thirsty is the number two answer 20
points
we got the final one
which is really dumb
it's really dumb
forgetting the stove it's almost self
it's oh i almost want to give it to you
with how stupid this one is just give it
um
waking up
not being able to sleep
not really i sleep like a rock like a
rock
yeah i know some people got sami i'm
like that sounds like yeah that was me
i idiot the other day oh my god the
other day i said you know what i kind of
have trouble sleeping so i'm gonna just
you know roll the joint
so i roll the joint and i said you know
what i'm gonna really sleep
so i roll the joint and i put oil
thc extract in there
passed out
how was kids not on the list that was
kids not on the list
kids are sex not on the list is wild to
me
yeah
yeah kid's not on the list is that but
it's not the right answer it's the most
popular answer yeah understand what i'm
saying but i feel like every parent
would say kids i understand but it
really depends what they call
ghostbusters because like parents tell
me like they don't sleep for like months
after oh yeah yeah yeah they're
definitely most definitely and even when
they're able to sleep mommy i can't
sleep
he starts crying
you guys want kids yeah
uh i might as long as they don't cry
tell them [ __ ] to shut up
they don't i'll leave them in the
[ __ ] pickup truck while i'm at the
strip club
[Laughter]
having a beer it's funny because i i
have i'm working on this project right
as that project and the person taking
care of the project has a baby and she
always has a baby with you with with her
i mean and it's funny because
i see how i'm not gonna google the
[ __ ] kid i don't got google kids
i don't i don't do the gag
shut the [ __ ] up i don't do that [ __ ]
i don't do that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you little [ __ ]
i was talking
i was talking to that kid like that and
she was like yo that's my kid mitch calm
down he's four months old he doesn't
give a [ __ ] what's good little [ __ ] and
i was talking to him like that but
that's how i speak to kids
i agree with you i i don't know why we'd
speak to them in a weird different way
keep that up till like six six seven i'm
like
i know i'm like yo and sometimes by the
time they're four or five they got a
better response they actually speak to
you like a well listen mommy i don't
really well that whatever the guy got
google thing i'm not my blank key you
want that dirty ass [ __ ] blanket yeah
i want my dirty ass [ __ ] blanket [ __ ]
you mean and then you have that
conversation that's great
it's vulgar yes it is
they ever call the little kid a [ __ ]
never asks fun things to do kids are
weird you listen stop stop like right
now right now you see i can understand
you so right now
right now you're being a little [ __ ]
right now you swear around kids um
it happened
yeah that's wild
[ __ ] is not swearing i feel like kids
you shouldn't be swearing around kids
[ __ ] is not swearing that's just me
though so what age though to what age
yeah you know listen i think
i don't know for me i think it's just
generally kids
for as long as possible you try to avoid
being vulgar around them i'm not going
to swear
but i think there's just a certain level
of decorum that you have i'm not saying
you got to be weird around the kid and
be like google gaga or anything like
that i mean i feel like swinging around
kids
that's just me is can agree
i can agree yeah yeah it's a bit [ __ ]
up yeah like i don't know it's just like
but i know i've seen parents swear at
their kids and it just throws me off
every time oh i i remember one time
i thought and that [ __ ] me up because
it was a parent talking to her kid
and she was
go cleaning your life the the
translation is like go clean your room
[ __ ] and i was like
that's wild you can't talk to your kids
like that
no i said no
that's a big no i was like yeah i do i
don't understand
but you know man why you got to be such
a little [ __ ] sometimes you even call
your kid little [ __ ] that's weird
it's not my skateboard i don't give a
[ __ ] that's weird like i know but like
it's called
weird i don't know i just can't get it
if i did it yo what's good little [ __ ]
and your kids are not black yeah that's
weird
yeah if you got a white chocolate hey
little [ __ ] kill you hey what's really
good though
i hope one day somebody [ __ ] names
our white kid little [ __ ]
makes their official real name pretty
sure there's going to be a white rapper
that's going to come hey my name is a
little [ __ ] because in the hood they
call me a little [ __ ] and you got to
write it really interestingly so that
they get a bit of leeway like l
i h l
lil
l-i-h-l
and
e-i
g-h
a-r little nieger
[Laughter]
it's scandinavian
that [ __ ] looked like a spelling bee
l-i-h-l-n-e-e-g-r
yes
little [ __ ]
can you use can you use that in a
sentence please go to sleep little [ __ ]
okay may i have the origin please
it's scandinavian [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's a kid name okay i got it
yeah i heard steve harvey sport his
daughter all the time
next round i'll be surprised oh i
remember remember uh you know who uh
never mind yeah
the gospel the gospel dude
the gospel dude that sings a lot of
gospel songs it makes a lot of money
about that and he there was a recording
of him screaming at something oh don't
[ __ ] with me i'll end you and he's like
supposed to be like super garlic and
like that like what the [ __ ] a calm down
i think i know what you're talking about
actually yeah
yeah it's great
great i'm like yeah
you're just like one of us peasant let's
go
next round round number two so far abba
in the in the lead 53-20 god damn name
something people like to hold on to
feelings
i'm going to give it to you memories is
actually number is the third answer ah
feelings of memory is not the same thing
bruh
that's a stretch you know that's a
stretch it's a little bit of a stretch
that's that's not a little bit that's a
long stretch
you're not a long stretch feelings and
memories is not the same fair [ __ ]
that's not the same thing
steve harvey says it's the same thing
okay all right steve harvey says it
though harvey yeah yeah with washington
harvey i already gave you the point so i
can't do it yeah we'll see marvin jp
cole over here
all right
okay so go ahead
okay cool
um
[Music]
old [ __ ]
old [ __ ] is not on the uh board
all [ __ ] is memories
this man said memories necessarily
feelings old [ __ ] memories
well if i got a phone i got a brand new
phone i hold on to old [ __ ]
huh that's a cool story she's definitely
memories
your time what do people hold on to
it's already your turn you don't have to
knock
uh pens is not on the board
pen nobody hold on to pence
we use pens a lot
literal i i ain't mad at it well it's
not literal
it is literal as well
both good answers though
let me give you style points let's go
literal
yes
i'm gonna go with random hands
can you be a bit more specific who's
hand your partner's hand like hand
holding or like you're getting a family
somewhere kid's hand kids is one of them
yeah hand-holding yeah you say hands i
didn't say [ __ ] i agree that's the
number two answer i'm gonna give it to
you yeah
we got three more here uh what else are
some people hold on to um
these nuts
hold on to his very like specific
warning it's it's not something like you
know i'm not specific actually no no but
it says like you wouldn't say people
hold on to food
no
but people do hold food in their hands a
lot
right so i wouldn't i wouldn't say they
hold on to food that sounds stupid no
it's not the same thing yeah what is
them that people hold on to um
steering wheels
they do hold on steering wheels though i
hope i mean everybody drives well you
know except when you got a tesla
yeah look ma no hands
yeah you're up
um
people hold on to me i got nothing else
gee that's just
go for it people hold on to their pants
[ __ ]
what's what would be something inside
their pants not genitals that they would
hold on to
the boxer breeze
he's trying to save pockets that that's
yeah something in your pockets
keys this guy's stretching this this
kind of stretches we're gonna get this
going we don't got it we don't get it we
got it
was it were you thinking about
wallets wallet oh it's on the board no
no no i said pants went from pants to
wallets
i didn't get that one i didn't get it
either no no no all right no points yeah
we'll do that we'll end this one here
we're not gonna split the points we're
not gonna try to number one answer i
think it's kind of obvious what what
no no i don't know think of something
physical that we're all obsessed with
phones
phone is the number one answer okay i'm
not mad at that hey man
i'll give you i'll give you half points
on that one fair
for a completely arbitrary reason
oh we said you can't give him points on
some [ __ ] we gave up on
i agree we do give up on this [ __ ] you
mean no points for phone no no point for
phone [ __ ] you mean
we decided to let it go [ __ ] you steve
harvey yeah that's right yeah you got to
give up on that one that that was a
weird category
but i'm not mad at it
all right
78 to 38 favor of abba of course
next round name something people
normally get insurance for car
r is the number two answer 24. go for it
half
house is uh number three at 21.
life
life is the number one answer 30.
pets
your turn
so you went you said what life lifehouse
car
those are the top three answers yeah i
would expect them to be the top three
answers
uh
medical insurance
not on the board i feel like in america
of all places
that should be like number two or two
like what
dantel
your turn
right i bought it so you can go again
if it's boat
go for it
boat
boat is number four it's definitely not
bow
he said boat but
we know medical insurance is way higher
yeah i know but this is this is a random
poll i got from fedex
[ __ ] retarts
crying about health insurance talking
about all this all the time calling
people votes both [ __ ] out of here
it's because the people who do [ __ ]
family feudal like suburbanites must be
you probably
yeah they i think they do these polls at
like walmart yeah they must
who
boat insurance like that should be so
far down the lake on the way to this
boat and you know yeah yeah you get boat
insurance yeah yeah that just rendered
it yeah is that it are we done yeah one
more oh look at this
um
is that dumb
oh one more from yeah there's one more
so we got the four we got car house
lifeboat and the last one i don't know
so you can go
laurier
yeah i don't know
it's phone
phone phone instruments
bruh just remember you disremember us
just remember phone
over medical medical and dental phone
entrance [ __ ] and bow entrance [ __ ]
[ __ ] are broken that's why
america is not functioning because
[ __ ] rather get
phone insurance rather than i didn't
even know that existed yeah damn i
didn't know phone insurance existed
phone insurance
wow next topic
free world the leaders of the free world
god damn bro next question jesus christ
of latter-day saints
name a popular action
and superhero
spider-man
spider-man is number two
batman
batman is number three superman
number one
26. um
iron man
he didn't make it wonder woman
[ __ ] loser did not make it
wolverine
either god damn go for it
robin is on the board
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is objectively wrong
[Laughter]
get on his face dude
this is how it happened in my head
i said uh i said uh iron man
then you went like wonder woman or some
[ __ ] and then you said robin i'm like
this [ __ ] just throwing an enhancer
away anyway that's right i said
[Laughter]
you know it's [ __ ] boomers answering
this question
it has to be boomers
you know what we [ __ ] up i should have
known boomers were the only ones who
know family feud
because only a boomer would answer that
yeah like young monies don't even know
who robin is robin when's the last time
robin been in a movie
robin when's the last
it's not even robin now it's night arc
it depends it depends on what yeah but
we switched we're not robbing no more
bro that's wild bro
that's funny
that's what i can tell from all the
insurance the reason why they're not
thinking about medical insurance i'm
about to die anyways [ __ ] so
give me a boat entrance instead bruh
i may die but at least my boat insurance
we just live with a cracks creed all our
lives we're like [ __ ] robin
that's wild there's one left right
there's one left
let's go be so busy
keep in mind after robbing catwoman
catwoman okay
these are boomers there are no there are
no females no female true true
that's funny you know what's funny i was
gonna say black panther because it's
boomers i know it's not no it's not that
naggers
what would boomers
watch aquaman
no
no that's too recent no it's not that
the flash
flash
there's a bit of a theme going around
all these
yeah yeah yeah something with man
a lot of them have been um
that's a very vague hit
yeah i don't know phone insurance is i
feel like it's tied to this a little
just say it captain america
that that should have been my accident
no man
very patriotic robin
yeah goddamn he came in at number four
robin was number four
a buff captain
you're
it offends me
it's offensive that's offensive
that's offensive okay
okay even superman like superman hasn't
been people's favorites in a long time
yeah because if you polled people today
i promise you iron man's way above
supposedly yeah definitely yeah
batman still gets all out of love
because we're not superman because
superman will be sucked and stupid well
it's not that because honestly if you're
a whole superman and you can get beat by
batman god damn even if you say stupid
back in the day he had a huge cult
following yes because in the comics and
all that stuff he was very very fine the
movie adaptations of him have been trash
if you think about it most people's
favorite superman thing is smallville
which is
[ __ ] teen drama in a way no there was
small villain there was one before that
that you don't remember
it was uh
what's this called
lois and clark or some [ __ ] like that i
have no idea i'm not going to say yeah
it was
basically
superman working at the metropolis with
um from top side i know what's happening
lewis was really hot yes she was [ __ ]
yeah yeah you had that [ __ ] captain
america butt chin thing going on yes
wild bro yes but lois lane in that movie
she must have been eastern european or
something because that [ __ ] was fire
just look for it i she had like deep set
eyes
and it's funny because lois in other
renditions isn't hot it's normally lana
who's hot who
in other additions is normally lana
who's the hot one
um lana is the other love interest of
superman
plus that's a whole other thing
that's nerd [ __ ] let me just jump over
lewis and clark yeah that was lois and
clyde show me show me picture lois and
clark yo
that was
bomb that was that [ __ ] right there
that was that [ __ ] right there jp you
don't remember that [ __ ] cause you were
three
hold on
no that's the [ __ ] on amazon
uh there you go scroll that [ __ ]
yeah
lois and clark
you can go on the computer and look for
lois and clark and see what i'm talking
about and do images yeah that [ __ ]
but yeah
yeah
it was dope it was all [ __ ] that was
that's a dope show that was fun yeah i
was supposed to look up superman and
lana she was hot too but anyways let's
roll it's close after after four rounds
it's 148 abba 146 preach oh okay
[ __ ] robin
now you got some [ __ ] answers
[ __ ] boat insurance [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
here sorry about that bro that's that's
gay
that's gay
anyways go ahead
what's that next round
name ways people usually change their
appearance plastic surgery
not on the board
these are boomers
go ahead
they change their hair color
dye their hair is the number one answer
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
get a haircut
haircut is a number two answer
it's so boomery bro this is like the
most boomer [ __ ] i've ever
go to the gym
yeah workout
makeup
[Laughter]
[ __ ] how's
oh
you see that's why the watch family feud
because it's not this motherfucker's
back
come back
no water
oh man wow
the working out is there because that
takes a while you know that's months
that's make up you can you can throw on
that money yeah that's funny
oh you mad man
mickey
oh that's great
[Laughter]
we got two more okay
okay
uh
sh i really don't know i think i did the
top one
um
lori harvey
go ahead
we've got one i think it's pretty
obvious and one that's really stupid
we got like a robin level one and then
we got like one that's okay
i'ma be stupid growing older
if you think about it
yeah think of these are more intentional
shaving
yes i'm going to give it to you grow
facial hair okay so you got the reverse
of that i'm going to give it to you cool
and there's one more we want to take a
stab at it
i don't know the last one is get a
tattoo
[Laughter]
oh my god i don't even know boomers
boomers are great
boomers are great anyways
i know this is wild makeup and plastic
surgery was not in there
that's crazy
plastic surgery i could grant you maybe
makeup [ __ ] oh bro
anyways
all right
i would argue that makeup is more common
than [ __ ]
growing facial hair
definitely
it's like all over the world women are
using that every day to completely alter
their face they literally change their
face yeah it does
i would argue that makeup has a bigger
effect than even
working out
yes it does
because
working out is months and months so you
look different there's women who you
take a before and after of it's not the
same not the same person no it's not but
all right
what next
next round okay so uh preach catapulted
into the lead there 238 abba's at 148
next round
name things you would bring to the beach
towel
towel is on the board
if this [ __ ] was not
i would sunscreen
[Music]
because white people did this and it's
just boomers so i know i'm starting to
see how yeah yeah yeah
um the umbrella thing
umbrella is the last one yeah
that's it
it's the the fifth out of five um so we
got three answer three you know what
else boomers bring often they bring them
[ __ ] chairs
not on the board however cool stereo
um
cooler
go for it god damn
bathing suit
do you know what's crazy i was going to
say that i was like [ __ ] hurry up and
say bathing suit
you went and i was like thank you
um
sandals
yeah you guys are going no bathing suit
no sandals
white people going naked
i feel like i named all the stuff that
you would 100 want hey yeah you named
plastic surgery that was not good okay
all right um
the other two are pretty dumb admitted
they're dogs
no no company
like
um
what else do people bring at the beach
boomers
um i already said towel
i said umbrella
i said uh sunscreen
what do i see people bringing at the
beach
um
the things to float in the water yeah
floatation device [ __ ]
because that's what i was thinking about
what did i see them old [ __ ] doing
that was it
what else have i seen old people doing
sunglasses
oh i thought i had it yet because that
[ __ ] bring that [ __ ] do yeah
that would have fit with the theme for
sure but this one stands out a little it
stands out yeah
it stands out
as in
it's not boomery
it's not boomer yeah
no i don't know just give it a reward
i literally was saying it
yeah you got it yeah you got it yeah i
was i had it on my head you got all five
so that catapult me first
okay so um yeah that's obviously adds up
to 100 right yeah okay so
it's 248 abba 238 preach still close
still close all right [ __ ] hey man
i'm thinking like a boomer yeah that's
what it's really you got you know what
do boomers do
yo that's so boomer
the fact that bikinis bathing suit
sandals weren't there i was like what
what kind of answer you guys given
surfboards
name things you might do in a bed
sleep together like sex just sleep i
think
yeah sleep sleep is the number one
answer at 26. but sex was number
sex is number two okay okay i thought i
didn't get it uh so sleep sex
um
that's some weird
[ __ ] it just it just dawned on me that
there's really two only two things that
i really think of uh watching a movie
watch tv is the number four answer okay
boomers again
i'm thinking boomers because they have
tvs inside their bed true
um and the last thing
because i really don't have too much
else two more slumber party
eat
eat is the number five that is
nasty
i could understand eating besides your
bed but just laying in your bed eating
[ __ ] oh yes my dad used to do it he
brought a whole plate in this mango
but they're watching tv yeah watching tv
okay that's different but he's eating
too yeah yeah i i i find it weird to be
i guess i i can understand why people do
it so i'm not gonna judge too hard
what else
is there alcohol in the bailey's
chocolate
i doubt it why are you for woozy yeah i
don't know why it's uh there's like a
liquidy thing in there oh no that's just
cream okay that's that whole that whole
try to make sure that's what the whole
candy busted your mouth
ah
you gay
uh
bailey's candy busting the sugary
thing in your mouth
uh what do we do in bed uh is that one
out of pocket it's it's one of the
dumbest things i could think of
all right listen to music
clip your nails
people do some people do that in the
metro i've seen that [ __ ] uh do you any
other ideas
i was going to say role play
boomers bro
all right what is it jump
it's always dumb
no see that's bloopers from the old time
imagining the old movies because we were
not people not jumping in anymore i
guess kids maybe do
yeah that's like one of the corniest
answers i could think of yeah i'm
jumping in the bed yeah
old random nance jumping in the bed yeah
that's cheesy
all right
we're gonna do a last one yeah we could
do one last one
um
[Music]
uh gifts to surprise a person you know
top five gifts you'd flowers
it's funny i was about to say yes and i
didn't even look it is not on the board
flowers is not on the board
sorry brother
can you repeat the question so the top
five gifts you would
you would give to somebody to surprise
them that you know gifts to surprise a
person you know
trip
trip is not
money
money is the number four answer
go again um
boomer car
our new car is the number one answer
all right go again
oh my [ __ ] man
certificates
gift gift card is the number
three
coupon
coupons
certificate coupons same gift card yeah
um what else
shoes
[Music]
clothes
yeah yeah
you gotta give them that clothes
yeah
close is number two
so there's only one more
pets
houses
car houses i get what you're saying i
mean cars people surprised over the cars
they're like surprised that's really
something that they did in commercials
okay you know i mean like the commercial
people will be like yeah here honey yeah
i did a
irresponsible decision without
consulting you surprise
you know i mean it's like
but
you know in all the in all the tv uh
commercials it's always that especially
around christmas
i'm gonna gift a car to my wife what's
your next answer
you said trips
right
hit it i don't know
uh electronics
i got one more cards
i got cologne perfume no it's jewelry
fair
fair fair
but flowers not on there
and cara is
it's just things they wish they had yeah
that's mom who thinks i wish they
received yeah oh people with people gift
uh i don't know a car and then she's
next to a husband yeah
a ring i feel like trips i don't know
yeah i feel like people gift each other
trips
all right let's do the last one no
because like uh because like sometimes
you're like your significant other
you'll give them a trip yeah hey
whatever yeah i'm surprised yeah i feel
like that's common between people it's
bad just makes sense gift cards make
sense i would definitely put those above
car i would not put number one
no that would be bottom
because it's not that common gift cards
yes
all the other stuff yes cars
something we see on movies yeah exactly
commercial number one don't really
happen that's wild that's a wish wishful
thinking that's interesting though
let's go so what's up
so points right now preach is in the
lead 342 ab at 313. okay let's go next
we're gonna keep going yeah one last one
sure we could do one last one
uh name ways to get rich quickly
okay wait okay
i was gonna say that was modern but i
realized
boomers boomers okay so i almost [ __ ]
up because i was about to go the whole
crypto route but i'm not going to do
that because that's stupid so
um
investing
investing is the number one answer
boomers boomers
saving
saving is the number two answer right
boom
uh
would
property be considered
i guess that's investing in a sense is
it yeah it is okay but i wouldn't give
that answer ways to make money get a job
bloopers it's absolutely on the bus
that's so boomers
i want money quick go get a job and cut
your hair yeah
yeah um exploiting poor people boomers
fraud was that on that that's not on the
board
not in the book fraud
what you got
i said fraud are you serious yes
um
hogging all the good jobs past
retirement stopping the next generation
from getting in lower
uh what else
also a form of investment for them i
think definitely
[ __ ] i don't know [ __ ]
over time that's working
working
investment
stealing and robbing a bank that's not
something they want to do
what you got
oh how much how do your parents make
money side hustles
no
no never
got a job they invested
save their money they save their money
they buy property
uh selling items selling stuff
that is very nice
crypto
bitcoin
[Laughter]
oh wow
i literally started this whole thing by
saying i was gonna say crypto but these
[ __ ] old geezers
oh [ __ ] this is good this is good good
wow technically crypto is investing but
yeah hey
there's a different forum invested yeah
it's like being like uh nfts or crypto
or it's like
it's investment but they don't get it so
yeah they don't think it is crypto
stupid people
[ __ ] boomers investors we have one
more left we got one more
uh the other one's boomer this one you
could almost i feel it right oven
you could almost what i was gonna say
you can almost win but
you would it would be so close if you
got this
investment
yeah that's number one answer investment
saving
working
crypto
sick of quick
stealing
not on the board
i would never condone that
uh bargaining
no
don't act like you haven't gp
okay
yeah
that's right so the winner is jp
that's pretty good all right
that's it for today uh thank you very
much for watching uh thank you very much
so uh congratulations [ __ ] boomers
[ __ ] boomers nah bro i'm sorry them
answers was wild bro you got mad some of
them were ridiculous you got triggered
how do you change the way you look
makeup's not on that [ __ ] you you got
[ __ ] you got triggered what happened
no they're all okay no all the one that
was most unreasonable wow wow wow makeup
no the
one the most
egregious was robin
robin was on the list no no no because
you know what i could see how the old
geezers
i could see how the old geezers loved
rob because back in the day robin and
batman was like it was a thing okay i'm
not mad i could kind of live with that
one you know once i accepted it was
boomers who were doing this
makeup [ __ ]
surgery
surgery even because like it's not as
common as makeup if yeah it's not it's
not everybody does makeup everybody does
makeup and they all do like these crazy
routines they buy the makeup industry is
money
booming on youtube that you you see
rihanna got
uh
yeah it became a billionaire
the jenner girl billionaire
is it's a big industry on youtube the
most profitable
genre to be in is makeup
because if you have like a fan base in
the electric tutorials you sell a makeup
line you're making like should we should
we start a makeup uh channel
i'm not
this [ __ ] would go on tv not refuse to
be to think hey can i do some makeup on
you for tv no i'm good everybody put
some like contour like you're not you're
not yeah you're not gonna change the way
you look oh if i look blemishes let me
look with some blemishes yeah but the
reflection who cares i remember one time
you went on tv right you went on on tv
and you looked so [ __ ] even but
that's not makeup they actually put
filters on oh yeah yeah
that interview did on ctv
yeah that was a whole filter yeah you
know what i'm talking about right tv
does that that's a whole filter yeah
they even out they do this weird stuff
to your face it filters out and you look
unnatural
it's like you don't let people have
their wrinkles that people have their
skin like what's the issue oh my god you
look the same on tv then yeah because
yeah but they have their standards and
they don't change they don't think until
somebody else comes along smashes the
whole thing yeah it's like when netflix
came along and smashed the whole like
you have to do one episode every week
and they just drop that [ __ ] all at the
same time people love that they're like
oh we can do this i can binge yeah
people like bill watching it's like [ __ ]
off so i think a lot of stuff on
television that just
yeah yeah but as far as makeup goes like
makeup rough number one oh yeah
comes close changing the way you look
makeup makeup makeup
makeup i have old sri lankan and indian
weddings where the lady starts out black
she does her makeup she's white she's a
white lady with a bendy in the middle of
her forehead yeah
i would argue that maybe
hair is like a second close not even
dying dying and i'm sorry dying is never
going to be as big as dealers cutting
her hair true the difference between
having super long hair and no hair or
just a shape up yes just a shape up it
don't have to be drastic for men you
just have a shape up you get your line
done yeah she all shaded like laser oh
you feel like a million bucks the only
thing missing is about a million dollars
yeah it changed the whole [ __ ] i will
put dying like towards the bottom of
that true i would put working out even
before that somebody who like completely
changed the way that they look
physically yeah that looks night and day
hair is just like okay you you want this
but even even working now just i mean it
doesn't necessarily change you
physically but the fact that you feel
better about yourself like just the
first time you you work out and you did
a good session you didn't shift in
weights or whatever what not but your
confidence makes you feel some type of
it makes you feel some type of way and
you're right like you you just you just
glow the glow up is nice yeah so yeah
even that not even like physically but
just the glow up these
[Music]
boomers plastic surgery you want to talk
about changing [ __ ] you can have a new
face permanently straight up wild
yeah wild right
i i met somebody recently who i didn't
know i knew
really you know what i mean because of
the platform yeah i saw their face i was
like oh i've never met this person and
then i looked at old pictures like oh i
know this person is you yeah that
drastic ah yeah just people are over
doing it and it's becoming so
commonplace that you're starting to
notice like even regular folks just
casually just getting titty jobs
getting their lips done or getting their
ass done bbl's yeah
yeah bbl's are really popular dudes
insane ones where it's like okay calm
down yeah come calm down stick legs
basketball we know when the thighs don't
match the booty we know yeah we know
yeah no one has a natural big booty and
skinny legs that never doesn't work like
that no no there's a proportion to
everything that has to make sense and
i've always kind of come to accept that
because
the skin around it stretches in a way
that doesn't make sense
you feel what i'm saying there's like a
disproportionate like that's not real
it's not possible yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah i'm looking at that same
thing with the lips yeah when someone
gets a lip job like the way the skin
pulls you can just tell them
there's something unnatural about it
like i've seen one with big lips
naturally and i'm like it looks a
certain yeah when you don't do it
naturally there's like a way that it
pulls it yeah it's weird it's not
nice they haven't perfected but that's
actually the aesthetic that they're
trying to look for you're trying to go
for that aesthetic and it doesn't really
look like it doesn't look
natural yeah but that's an aesthetically
challenging everybody that got lip
injection right now their lips look the
same their lips look kind of the same
yeah even the ones that say like now i
want lip suggestion but i want my [ __ ]
to look like natural and i'm like
okay i could tell doesn't look natural
there's a girl here like a youtuber here
from montreal like this white girl and
she had her stuff done and i was like
you look at her and like you can tell
yeah it looks very faint because she had
no lips so you go from nose to someone's
like oh okay reasonable and you look at
your lips it looks weird yeah it looks
off
you know but for these people it makes
sense to them and the thing about lip
injections is it one of my homies i
don't think it's one of your homies okay
never mind you have to do them often
yeah because because you're because your
body consumes that silicone yep it's
[ __ ] up and that's dangerous because i
think that could create cancer and [ __ ]
like that um
yeah fillers fillers both a friend of
mine who like there's still some in
there and it still like has effects on
her
yeah people are doing wild stuff to
their bodies um and i'm just like listen
i get it you know there's a lot of
pressure but i'm like that's nasty
that's nasty yeah
and you kind of like you said it like
you end up looking like the same person
like there's like you're trying to
achieve this particular aesthetic that
isn't natural the goal isn't to look
like better but natural it's a look like
this weird
like like instagram like there's like
this instagram like [ __ ] doll look you
know what i mean where it's like
everyone wants to look like that yeah
you ever see that uh south korean um
like uh miss south korea in like 2018 or
something they had a picture of
everyone's face yeah like went viral and
they all looked identical
it's slightly different than the western
instagram thing where it's like big
stuff because they're all about like
softening you know yeah but until they
still go to the they still go to their
uh uh
surgeon and they'd be like
make make this exactly do this
and everybody's like they have the same
reference do this
and you know that's what they do they
just they just go and do exactly
replicate that you walk through certain
areas of soul you're like
i saw that girl over there i saw her
there you're like he just clones it just
clones yeah it's wild and now now they
get the they get the boob job and they
get the lipo for the rest because they
they really want to look like stick
figures in the bottom and big cut up you
know
yeah so they all a lot of them look like
that it's crazy the same face yeah same
face it's not even something racist they
all look alike no no no no they all look
you know
yeah yeah
anyways that's it for today thanks very
much for watching and follow all the
patreon and all the channels that we
have uh peace [ __ ] dessert